hi and welcome to another episode of get
close i am your co-host gio and i'm your
host bart
how come you look at me with such a
dirty face i'm just ready for anything
oh but you just were like like let me
see your face what does it look like i
was like hi and then what do i look like
like
oh really yeah
oh maybe i was just ready for anything i
don't know what's going to happen which
is ironic it's my game face so i'm like
what are you going to do what are you
going to do throw at me that one
that was so what are you saying i don't
i don't be throwing something crazy okay
which is ironic because today i wanted
to talk about how um you're always such
a happy person
really i am happy i know but like your
face was such a [ __ ] rbf moment that
i was like
i apologize oh what's going on i think
is this my game face have you ever
played me basketball or whatever
jiu-jitsu i look like this
no you don't i don't no you goof off all
the time oh you're a goofy dude that's
why it threw me off that's true
how come you're so happy all the time
what's going on in your brain
i don't know i just feel like
don't be sad
[Laughter]
okay um
what the [ __ ] is going on with your nose
also
i don't know it's you know what's crazy
i get my nosebleeds in california which
is so like counterintuitive in nevada
exactly so um i just came back from
california so watch in two days no more
nosebleeds right chilling and then i go
to california nosebleed and i always
bring it back what do you think is
happening i don't know because nevada is
drier which makes sense if i have
nosebleeds yeah
and it's more humid in la so it would be
less nosebleeds right but the thing is
i've been to taiwan nosebleeds i've been
to
um
california houston wherever all humid
places all nosebleeds
and um what i think it is is that nevada
since it's drier yeah because it's a
baby bleed it dries immediately so i
actually get less nosebleeds even though
it's dry and have you noticed your
boogers out here are super crusty crusty
as hell i hate it well i like it and i
hate it i like it because like it's
easier to clean out yeah they're
flickable
what do you mean because the one in
california right you like this oh like
it gets like you're trying to like
you're picking your nose you don't want
anyone to look right and then as you
pull it out you're like cool and as you
pull it out you're like why is it still
connected to my nose and this is long
string right so it's like it's not
flickable because you go like this or
something it might go whoopsh you know
that thing that twenty-five centimeter
that you get the [ __ ] hand yeah it's
like a [ __ ]
like that and you're like oh jesus
that's how you got to do the roll
technique i've seen you do it uh those
are um
when it's like ready to be uh like surf
wax
oh yeah like a glue yeah when it's like
oh this is good someone give me a
surfboard and i don't know that stringy
one because that one is like a vavoso
like it's like uh you ever get those
string ones
not like that no it's either super wet
or it's like that like like you can make
it into a ball one oh it's probably
because i have sonitis all the time
maybe what the [ __ ] is tinnitus it's
like bronchitis before your sinuses did
you just make that [ __ ] up no that's for
real i told you i'm smart you don't
believe me i'm gonna look this [ __ ] up
tell me the truth isn't that real yeah
give me the definition of tinnitus i
don't know the [ __ ] definition and
nobody knowing those definitions
sonitus well this is an idious
whatever
now i don't know i i don't know if
you're [ __ ] with me or not oh what
i'm just saying is uh but then here
because it's crusted up you could go
like you could literally like feel the
scoop like and then when no one's
looking he's go okay wait can i ask you
another question yeah
um
because
you pick your nose and there's a
a lot
and like you pick your nose like no one
is watching literally when everyone can
see what you're doing
are you serious okay
um i have a video on my tic tac i mean
on my tick tock on my um instagram reels
uh of you just going in picking your
nose
and as you're so the reason why i'm
thinking about this is as you're
describing your nose-picking you're up
here uh-huh
but i go like here
what the [ __ ] is your objective
when you're sticking your finger in your
nose and how high do you think it's okay
to go well you're not getting at the
root causes
so so okay so wait
what's happening in your nose in the
first place when you're like shaving
your legs okay do you take the clipper
and just like gently graze the top hairs
or do you hit your skin and you drag it
across and make sure it's clean and you
rinse it in the water this the ladder
exactly so the way you pick your nose
would be wait wait the way i shave my
legs no the way you pick your nose oh it
would be the way if you took a razor and
you're just like
like just dabbing it no but i'm
accomplishing what i'm trying to
accomplish nah there's a lot up there
but i'm not trying to wait what okay so
what happens up there because i never
feel compelled to go past
like the cave part right like there's
like the wide entrance cave which is
your nostril hole yeah
right so i like kind of just clean in
there
and then there's like this narrow
crevice cave yeah where like
you just have no wiggle room yeah and i
feel like you're trying to go in there
yeah that's just because i'm a deep
person and you're superficial no what
the [ __ ] you're just into [ __ ] no
no
maybe i am no you're superficial like
you only stay on the surface right and
i'm very like i'm very like deep and i'm
very empathetic so i go really back
there yeah but what's back there what do
you feel
[ __ ] more boogies
really yeah
well i don't understand that because
they're stringy
it's a stringy boogie yeah
but you feel it back there yeah that's
what i'm saying when i pull it out it's
like that sticky hand right because the
the ones down here okay so if i were to
break it down in a non-scientific way
there's literally like a fisherman back
there right with a fishing reel of
boogies so he's going like this to fish
from my finger and it's just down here
wiggling around and that's what most
people feel but because i'm experienced
i'm like i know the fishing line goes
all the way up there so what i do is i
grab that one and then i pull the whole
fishing line in and sometimes if i blow
hard enough the whole fisherman comes
out
yeah um now i'm beginning to believe
that you weren't born with
whatever like bloody nose like uh
[ __ ]
syndrome missing tissue that you have
it's just thin capillaries that are very
close to the surface of the skin which
is easy to rupture yeah and i think you
did that yeah
you ruptured your own capillary
well thank you
thank you very much why why would
someone do why would you do that i don't
know i'm doing it on purpose i'm just
trying to clean my nose in a good way
you know you do a lot of things that i
think everyone does like this so i think
there's a one way
um
that everyone does things on their body
right so i think everyone eats
generally the same way like they'll grab
a spoon kind of the same way like you
have some people that grab the handle
this way weird you're weird or like kind
of like the pencil technique right
you don't even know where i'm going i
know where they're going right you're
weird
or like they brush their teeth a certain
way and there's like slight variations
right like and the variation you can
kind of see the thought process and you
kind of see how they arrive to this yeah
but literally everything that you do
there it like
there's there's the average way and then
there's like the slight deviation weight
and then there's bar like
on some [ __ ] other planet well we all
have different training
oh okay
how do you know what i'm talking about
just like you're just talking about how
mine's way different than anyone you've
ever seen yeah like literally everything
like something as simple as even rubbing
your eyes yeah
you'll rub your eyes for literally three
to five minutes i told you i'm having an
orgasm
how
my eye feels good i'm going like this
i'm like it's like rubbing like so what
do you feel first it feels like a
clitoris almost you're just it just
feels so good and just you don't know
what the [ __ ] where or what the clitoris
is so don't even throw that out there
just throw the [ __ ] you're aware of okay
dude yeah it's right well i'm a master
of the clitoris because you're missing
clitoris that's the pee hole dude then
this one
i go like this and i feel it
ironically enough your eyes do resemble
vaginas
that would be where the clitoris is so
like is it in the corner no it's every
it's literally the whole thing so it's
one of those things where like you ever
like get a mosquito bite yeah and
sometimes scratching on the side feels
better than right on top
no absolutely not what are you talking
about so you don't like foreplay but
that is foreplay yeah but that's like
i'm trying to get to the source i'm not
trying to play games
i'm trying to get my version of the
fisherman out you know what i mean yeah
and that's what i'm doing
i get to the stores too but then i don't
neglect all the other lady parts
so so what happens it's the corner that
itches or is it you have dry eyes or is
it like on the
lash line if i were to really like break
it down
from what i've read it's actually
probably like an adhd thing
and it and flame thing
inflammation
yeah i know what i'm playing but what do
you mean so like uh what i noticed and i
see this in taiko a lot which is pretty
crazy
um i i was reading about how like you
know like sometimes you'll see me like
you're like like why are you scratching
so much or whatever right or like like
stretch or whatever
and people with adhd
they have random quirks
and i think that those quirks
actually help them concentrate
because you know when you have adhd it's
not that you can't focus you just focus
on too many things yeah so when you
preoccupy one side of your brain and the
other side is able to focus
which is why sometimes it seems like
type is not paying attention or
sometimes it seems like um
i'm not good at driving right but the
minute i start texting i'm a really good
driver
don't say that because that's not true i
know that's just a joke but anyways like
there's a lot of times where like if it
wasn't a joke you [ __ ] suck at
driving okay but when i'm using a gopro
on like
on the scooter if i take a gopro and i
go scuba diving i'm like 10 times better
of a scuba diver that's just how adhd
works right and so i think uh the
scratching and then like the random
stretching you'll see taika do
especially when he's nervous
the reason why he's doing that isn't
because he's not trying to pay attention
it's he's actually because he's trying
to pay attention that's his body's form
of trying to pay attention so we're like
trying to teach him a lesson right any
standard attention he starts going like
this him scratching is actually him
preoccupying one side of the brain so he
could pay even more attention but then i
think to the person that doesn't know
you just think oh this guy's trying to
get out of this or whatever or just
squirm it but he's not but anyways i
think the eye the eye scratch and all
that it's a part of mine it's my matured
way of doing that so i think there's an
adhd component where like i scratch my
eyes a lot or like i just i'm an itchy
person or whatever the other part the
inflammation part
ever since i was a kid when i would go
see like a chinese herbalist where uh
like those acupuncturists they've always
said i'm like
uh
like what is it called um
i forgot how to say it in chinese yeah
weird um like i have a lot of heat i'm a
heat kid
what does that matter so like they'll
look at my lips it's always red looking
so they're always trying to prescribe me
um stuff [ __ ] yeah it's supposed to like
bring me down so like cucumbers stuff
like that i'm not supposed to be eating
like fried food i'm not supposed to be
eating
like like ginseng too much because it's
really like inflaming people that are
naturally cold you want the stuff that
warms you up
and
when you're naturally more inflamed you
have a lot of blood circulating and i
think that's what causes the itch to
begin with so that's why i even feel the
itch to begin with kind of like you
don't get a mosquito bite the reason why
it just is because it's inflamed yeah so
naturally like if you look at my palms
it's just red
all the time
like the minute i grab a barbell my face
turns red like i've been on steroids
even i've never taken stairs in my life
you know so it's just i think my
circulation
is just hot like all the time so because
of that it's very easy for me to itch
a couple that with adhd like tendencies
then i'm just scratching all day i love
how you like break a bunch of [ __ ] down
yeah and you have a white cinnamon roll
just [ __ ] sticking out of your nose
the entire time why what's wrong with
that
it's just it's just hard to focus oh
well then me you might need adhd so you
can actually focus no no no i can focus
really well you can't you just thought
you can't find this you don't have
everything you can't focus you don't
have you don't have how old are you
you don't have like out of out of body
experiences every day every time yeah so
like i'm listening to you but then i can
see myself looking at you and then going
this whole thing is [ __ ] hilarious
you want a cookie or something
are you trying to fight what the [ __ ] is
going on i just cherish these moments so
much because i rarely get a chance to
talk to you one on one yes so all you
want to do is just [ __ ] get me riled
up and have my [ __ ] feathers be all
ruffled and [ __ ]
orange talk like i was saying you're
trying to do something
yeah i'm [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] just trying
to relax myself fine and for some reason
this relaxed to me i don't know why
that's cutie pie you big stupid idiot
so we're going to ask him about being
happy or whatever
um
i mean does that even matter at this
point
no so like
um when i think about okay so the reason
why i'm thinking about this was because
this morning
it was your turn to wake taika up yeah
so um we both have super busy schedules
so we
i love that about our relationship that
we get to like support each other in
whatever endeavors we're trying to
personally achieve so um we both like to
train
um but we just don't have the time
sometimes so we'll split the parent
duties today was your day to get taika
up get him ready and it was my time to
like go in my meditation room aka our
garage gym and just work out
and um
you're in there
and i it's quiet and then i just hear
one of his favorite songs i'm blue
okay what is it i feel [ __ ] 65 yeah
and um
then like he slowly like of course i'm
being a nosy ass [ __ ] i'm like oh man
fun times so i go run into the room and
then i'm watching him and he like starts
to wake up and he immediately wakes up
with a smile and he's always like waking
up with a smile which i think i
contribute that to your genes
because that's how you've always been
you've always been someone that just
wakes up and is just either neutral in
behavior or just like super
happy and i think the neutral behavior
probably comes if you're trying to match
my not behavior but mood
i think the neutral part
is because you're trying to match me
which i tend to be a grumpy person yeah
every morning i wake up i'm so happy she
won't jump on you
but then i but then the times that i did
were you all grumpy and stuff
so i'm like oh yeah i've always been a
grumpy so now like i don't jump on you
anymore i don't hug or really like kiss
you that much i let you have your own
space yeah yeah i i didn't know that i
was i mean i knew it was like that
um i know there's people that are way
more severe on the grumpy side but like
you're just so [ __ ] happy why are you
so grumpy what's the uh
do you think it's like the last dream
you had was sad can you always have that
or something no i think i just want to
stay sleeping
i'm like a bear like let me hibernate so
when you're sleeping you're happy if
something woke you up then you're upset
because it took you from your happy
place yeah oh yeah and i'm like oh what
are you doing
yeah and then i think i start thinking
about that feeling too much of going
like oh i want to sleep why is
everything so bright why is everything
so loud yeah oh
what do you think
well i'm trying to think right like when
i wake up on my own obviously i'm happy
because it's on my terms
right so i'm like okay cool it's not
because your alarm's going
well that's not on my own
that's not on my own you're still happy
no so when i'm i'm trying to
like i'm trying to pinpoint so if i wake
up at eight right which is on my own or
seven on my own
um i'm happy because it's on my terms i
don't have an alarm clock on i just
naturally wake up at that time i feel
the sun on my face it feels good it
feels like i get a whole new day i get
to do whatever i want it's the beginning
of the day you can't go wrong i feel
like i start with a blank sheet of paper
nothing has gone no one hit my car or
nothing like that right
and then let's say a
background you think of all that [ __ ] in
the morning i don't logically think of
it right i feel it when i wake up in the
morning i feel like a blank sheet of
paper i feel like fresh laundry nice and
crisp and it feels good yeah that's how
i feel like every morning
that's amazing yeah the minute i wake up
like if i could describe my day
like let's say i'm sleeping right and
obviously it's warm and it feels really
good especially if the ac is on
then i'm like when i wake up i'm like
it's a new day it feels like christmas
morning like the way movies paint
christmas morning when all the kids
can't wait to open their present yeah
the day is my present
and i can't wait to open it and see
what's gonna happen that's so cool i'm
so jealous yeah so like i'll wake up and
that's the feeling like i wake up and
i'm like what cool stuff is gonna happen
right and i'm older now so i'm just
laying in bed or i'm like i i'm more
like uh what is it called it's more of a
cerebral feeling
tyka the minute he wakes up you just
hear his two feet hit the ground because
he's gonna make it happen but we feel
the same thing and i know where it's
coming from because you're like wait
this kid literally was just eyes closed
his eyes are open and now he's like
speedy gonzales like where does all his
energy come from and i think it's the
same thing as a christmas morning where
he just wakes up
bright new day and just
of course his favorite place to go is
our bed so just runs and jumps into our
bed and even like i don't know if you've
ever seen him like get to our bed he
doesn't want to wake us up right he has
his like little blanket and he's like he
just yeah yeah yeah
this can't contain it yeah like if he if
we were more receptive he would just
jump all over us but since he knows that
we're sleeping he's like
just tickles the feet a little bit
like that so that's how i feel but just
like a 37 38 year old version of that
where i still feel it on the inside
and then
yeah like when i go brush my teeth it's
nice and happy
[Music]
where did this come from you were just
naturally born with it
i thought it came from somewhere well
actually i thought it came from my mom
yeah i remember that story where like i
cried once and then my mom beat the crap
out of me where she told me like you
better wake up with a smile every
morning what the [ __ ] is beat the crap
out of me i mean though
uh well so for that age it wasn't like
feather dusters but it's more like uh
like a lot of chastising oh like that
kind of stuff you know and then and then
maybe it's so different maybe a couple
of slaps or something here and there oh
yeah yeah yeah so probably a couple
slaps and that stuff and then like
and i was like okay i gotta wake up with
a smile
and then i don't know what happened um
but with taika we never done any of that
and he's been a happy baby
always yeah like even since swaddling
you know you take the swaddle and he's
like
yeah
he's just like so happy yeah
yeah
damn
i don't feel any of that so for me
when i wake up it has to be on my own
terms for me to kind of settle into like
my body into this [ __ ] planet like
into this time
like i do like waking up with the sun on
my face i do like birds chirping i do
like that
but i'd like it to be slow
maybe do you think it's a contribution
of adhd maybe
where everything's just kind of sped up
it could be um because
a few years ago you know how we got our
brains scanned yeah and then when we got
our brain scan at that like uh like by
that uh ucla neuroscience professor
he says he can sense i have high
cortisol in the morning yeah what's
cortisol so cortisol is the stress
hormone yep but stress not in the way
that layman's take it yeah so the
average person the casual person that's
using the word stress
thinks of it as a negative thing right
because usually stress is just means
there's extreme stimulus and now you
need problem solving so for the regular
person when they feel stress they're
like oh something [ __ ] happens i can't
pay the bills or whatever you know
that's that feeling
from a scientific point of view
high cortisol the stress hormone just
means i'm in problem solving and
activity mode stimulation mode
so when i as soon as i wake up he said
you can tell i have high cortisol
so for me to be put to like to like take
advantage of uh
my cortisol levels he's like he says he
recommends me as like one of those guys
the first thing i should do is do
something productive like that fits like
mental or physical anything that's
that's what's gonna fit my hormonal
peaks yeah and he says everyone has
cortisol
uh spikes right randomly right so you
you hear about like the quintessential
like midnight artist yeah those guys
probably get a high cortisol at night
where they're like oh i'm in the zone
now hell yeah right yeah but i get mine
in the morning as soon as i wake up yeah
so that's probably the similar feeling
if people like once they get to like 10
like you know there's some artists
they're like they can't wait till it's
10 so they can work on their art that
was me and then now they're like now i'm
going to open up my christmas present
yeah that's probably what i feel the
minute i wake up and that feeling is so
strong it feels like a hit of caffeine
whoa
like i could be tired right like i wake
up at 4 00 a.m
and like my body is so tired i want to
go to sleep but the um
like that's so strong it'll compel me to
wake up
so i remember like when i used to go uh
visit my my family in asia
and you know you're just jet lag or
whatever right
as soon as that hits me i get up and i
can't go back to sleep even though i'm
exhausted like i'm so tired i wanna just
sleep just sleep but as i'm sleeping
it's literally like
dudes dudes like that and i find on get
up so i'll watch tv for like five hours
until everyone else wakes up
because that that feeling that cortisol
hit is so strong i need to do something
damn yeah
that is so interesting okay but like
don't you think that
so the cortisol problem-solving energy
cast natural caffeine get out of bed do
something type of [ __ ]
that doesn't necessarily correlate with
being happy though no i don't think so
yeah so that's the part i'm like what
the [ __ ] because your your mindset's so
positive you're like brand new day blank
slate like these are all positive things
where the [ __ ] does that come from this
podcast is sponsored by better help
life can be overwhelming and many people
are burned out without even knowing it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless or trapped detachment
fatigue or
more
i know i start feeling burnout
for sure when i just work too much i
don't sleep enough and i don't get
quality time with my family and friends
that are the
biggest factors when i start feeling um
unmotivated
you know so um
i really do try to look out for those
things
and um we tend to associate burnout with
work but that's not the only cause
any of our roles in life can lead us to
feel burned out and better help online
therapy wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
and i absolutely love that because when
i've felt burnt out before i didn't even
realize i was burnt out i just thought
that i was changing and unfortunately
this change was very heavy and negative
and it wasn't until i started talking
about it that i was like whoa
i'm actually experiencing burnout but a
lot of us don't have access to um
speaking to people that we trust and can
confide in um and also some of us might
live in areas where
you know we don't have the help that we
need because maybe we live in a super
rural rural area
um but better help is here to help
better help is customized
online
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
and you just don't feel comfortable
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours
get close listeners yep you guys are
gonna get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
slash get close that's better help h e l
p dot com slash get close g-e-t
c-l-o-s-e
maybe just choices
like choosing to be happy
yeah so so you wake up and there's like
you're feeling different things
um
and you're like nab
never rain hello sunshine
i think i mean who i am now it's
probably
so i never know right i never know if
it's like nature versus nurture
like i never know if i conditioned
myself to be this way right or you were
just born or if i was born that way
because i
thought i would have conditioned myself
to be this way like i remember like my
first hit and run like someone hit my
car right and just drove off and i look
at it obviously my first feeling was
like oh my god what the [ __ ] no i gotta
spend like a grand fixing this [ __ ] you
know and then my second thought is like
okay either i can be this grumpy guy all
day because someone hit my car or maybe
i should kick in the other side so it
looks funnier
and then make make make make it happy
right like what's my choice do i want to
be like oh it's my crew where did you do
it to my car there's so many other cars
where they hit the car or i could just
go do something about it and i think
just like little things like that yeah
where does that come from then i'm gonna
get deep today i don't know i think just
uh
choosing do i wanna be sad or happy
because life is always going to happen
yeah and um i'll get to that and then
but so i always thought maybe it's
something i slowly trained myself
right and then like and that's all
actually a muscle that all comedians
have right like the sickest of canadians
the sickest of comedians can literally
make fun of like ukraine and russia
conflict yeah right you know we'll all
laugh about it because wow what a great
perspective yeah if they're good yeah
yeah if they're like the sickest ones
right yeah so like um so that's actually
a muscle that you exercise to be able to
change perspectives like flip to 180
yeah and turn something painful on its
head right like kevin hart's special
laugh at my pain yeah
but
um
now that i see taika
and even if he just banged his toe and
he's in pain like he's in pain for less
than like 10 seconds and i think he has
an out-of-body experience and he starts
laughing because he realized like the
probably the position he's curled up in
is like the funniest thing he could ever
think of or something so i'm like wow is
that
genetic then is that uh nature yeah what
i thought was nurturing like is that
nature yeah
you know [ __ ] so we're just never gonna
know
i i really
don't know and i think um it could be
i'm naturally like that yeah
but also as i got older and you know
like
i think when you're young
you're really impulsive
so you don't know you have
conversations with yourself yet you know
it's literally like candy and then you
just want it
versus when you're older you're like i'm
on a diet if i eat that candy
like you have like so many you could
think
long term short term you could think all
kinds of stuff you know like are gonna
have cavities like you can think all
kinds of stuff
and when i was in that more have a
conversation with yourself face
i was able to see literally every time
something good or bad happen
i can see choices and it was up to me if
i want to be happy or
sad about it yeah do you think you model
this off of anyone
it's hard right it's hard to think back
but like
um well i always think back to my
parents my dad's grumpy for sure
like i i've he's never been like the
optimistic guy
um
but i think my mom's pretty optimistic
yeah i think my mom likes i remember
like
the first time i moved out
it was i came back so i had a really
rocky relationship with my dad right to
the point where we're like throwing
stuff all the time
like pissed at each other you're not my
son like those type of things were
thrown around a lot
and then i would sleep at my friend's
house i'm like out of here and
i would get so pissed on my mat for
three days so obviously i can't even do
school or concentrate you know
so when i came back from the marine
corps
i was very determined to change my life
around
and we would still have the same type of
relationship so i'm like man there's no
way i'm gonna do well in college if like
if i'm trying to use the marine corps as
like a launch pad for the rest of the
success for my life
there's no way
um this
turbulent relationship at home is going
to be good for school
so i was starting to look for places to
move out to and when i talked to my mom
about it
like my mom was like okay well how much
do you get from gi bill and that kind of
stuff and also at the time you know i
get like 500 bucks a month uh i could
probably work so i could probably get a
place that's like 800 bucks and i'll
have a little bit extra cash for
spending money whatever and so we're
just like uh
talking about it and
in that moment was when my mom was
starting to think about well what if
what if like she's going to have some
equity in my house what if i buy a house
and then you rent for me and your other
buddy also rents for me then instead of
the money going down the drain and
attempting rentals
you'll be paying off a mortgage and then
over a few years like
that house eventually could be yours if
you can get it cheap enough and all that
so like i think that like turn lemons
into lemonade i probably got that from
my mom because i was always finding like
i always felt like this positive
like drive at the end even when i'm cool
even if i got kicked out of school
obviously getting my ass whooped right
but then afterwards she was like hey you
know what i found this military school
and it might be cool because then you
could teach her some of these things so
i think like after you hit the bottom
maybe i got it from her where she's
always like okay so now we hit the
bottom so on the right the rise to the
top there's a nice light we just got to
follow it's got to follow that
brightness dang baby i have the wrong
person in this seat i want to talk to
her
that's such a dope gift to have to be
like okay cool we can't get any worse
than this let's go let's go back up yeah
that's [ __ ] cool
is it
what do you mean of course
i don't see anything negative coming
from that you know what i mean it's a
kick kick them down for like as much as
you want but they don't stay there for a
very long time yeah i think that's a
[ __ ] superpower
yeah that's sick as [ __ ]
and i know that like even at my core i'm
like that
that i'm like happy
because like in mma
like when i'm getting my ass beat
i knew you were gonna go there yeah
cause i'm like
thank you
yeah i'm like that's a good one or i
could get might just get there and get
my ass be like
what am i getting [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up man you know or
just take it and have fun with it and
start you can't hit me here oh you can't
hit me here you gonna hit me here and
then just
you know just like what aren't you
scared you're gonna roll them up and
they're really gonna all [ __ ] your ass
up and be like shut up you [ __ ] goof
then
i gotta be even more creative
that's amazing yeah well then you're
actually no help to me then because i'm
trying to
i'm trying to pinpoint where i can shift
my [ __ ]
um to be more like that and you're like
i don't know well what about let's start
with you then what about do you when
something bad happens do you see two
choices like right away okay okay
somebody choose the grumpy choice
i think i think i'm not as grumpy as
like the average person
i definitely do think i'm i'm way up
more on the positive end
um
but then i see you and you're like on
some [ __ ] godly level really of
happiness yeah oh like even when we used
to fight like crazy right
um like the regular [ __ ] toxic couple
fights
you would bounce back really fast unless
it was like some [ __ ]
heartache [ __ ] i felt like you'd be a
sad little sad little puppy
really yeah cause i'd be pissed for
hours
and then you're like joe and the [ __ ]
asian mom says skit where you're like
[ __ ] pissed and then yeah someone
calls you like hello how's it going when
i'm pissed i don't give a [ __ ] who's
called i'm hanging up on all of them
like everyone calls my [ __ ] just hang
up on oh my god [ __ ] time for this
but i'm so pissed
i don't have selective pissness so when
i see you when i see you and the
neighbors i go hi and you're like hi
like i'm like whoa that's [ __ ] crazy
really yeah that's so funny because that
same um
like shift that i can do
is something you say you can do when
stress is involved right like for me
when there's work [ __ ] happening
i can't separate it and i'm like my
motion of stress i drag it in every
[ __ ] aspect of my life so i can't
hang out with you guys because i'm
thinking about work [ __ ] and you're like
yeah me too but i just can't
compartmentalize it
and then i'm like i'm like wait what do
you mean you can't
compartmentalize [ __ ] i don't know i
can't say that uh your happiness and
pissness it's the same it comes from the
same place that's crazy so
how come you can compartmentalize
relationship fights yeah or relationship
stress yeah but you can't
compartmentalize work stress i wish i
knew because if i knew that answer i
would [ __ ] do that because like i'm
not pissed at everyone else i'm just
pissed at you and i want to talk to you
wow that's crazy yeah i'm like they
didn't do anything wrong you're the one
that pissed me off mine's the opposite
because i can compartmentalize work
stress
because that's work
i can't compartmentalize like the stress
i get from you because you are my life
yeah but what did all the other people
do to you why do they get that version
of you what do you mean i can
compartmentalize it no you said you
can't because you're hanging up on
[ __ ] everyone that's [ __ ] close
yeah because you're my life
that's cute i know it's cute so when i'm
stressed from my life
then that's the whole that's the whole
me are you saying my priorities are
[ __ ] up
it could be i don't know
i'm not saying anything i'm just saying
i know you're not saying it i'm not
saying that you're saying i just
more of a rhetorical
or maybe more of a question to myself
yeah for me it's just like if if
if i'm [ __ ] up with you and you're my
life
then nothing else matters that's true
so i'm like you know what i think it is
i think i don't want to let a lot of
people down
so i think that's why it probably
stresses me because i know there's so
many things that count on me yeah
i agree yeah but i also know that in
terms of work
no one else is thinking that
i see you know what i mean like everyone
has and that doesn't stress you out that
no one else is thinking about oh because
it's an agreement we all have right so
we when we have a work group our
agreement is we're going to work
together
right so i know people that have kids
dinner time i'm sure they're not
thinking about what the next sick work
idea is i know they're having dinner
with their kids just like how i'm gonna
have dinner with my kids so for me it's
very clear on like
uh what we're trying to do with our time
and our shared initiative yeah the only
thing that transcends hours and projects
is you and me
interesting so speaking on
getting our
uh brain scanned at that neurological
center yeah um
that guy that doctor told me that i'm a
high functioning person
with a lot of anxiety okay and that's
that's what attributes to a lot of like
my successes if you will because my
brain never turns off and it's
constantly trying like [ __ ] trying to
problem solve a bunch of [ __ ]
which sucks because then that's what
could probably be attributing or
contributing to
um me not being able to compartmentalize
but you can compartmentalize us
like how do you how do i piss you the
[ __ ] off
and you can go and like work and do
stuff
that's true because i see it as so
different
you piss me off yeah my whole being is
pissed
right so if my whole being is pissed i
can't do jk i can't do barbell brigade
stuff i don't even want to i don't want
to go play basketball with people i
don't want to do nothing why what
happens my whole being is pissed it's
like is that me it's like this you break
my arm right i don't know if i've ever
even been that level to that pistol
either if you break my arm yeah you hurt
my being right yeah
i can't i don't magically go oh time to
lift weights
i compartmentalize that broken arm for
my weights right oh i compromise my
broken arm for jk
it's you hurt my being
whether it's physical or emotional or
mental whatever feel as big as you do
then maybe but what i'm saying is uh
when you hurt my being
that's that but when i'm like talking
about work stuff that's like uh you're
not hurting my being it's like someone
like they um
they they crash into my car right they
crashed into my car wow that sucks i
parked my car in the garage when i'm
going on a five-mile hike with my
buddies
i don't even remember it cause that's
not my being
that's what i'm that's what i'm talking
about when my relationship with you is
my being it's my heart it's like how i
feel
damn me i don't know if i've ever even
been that sad
well how come you can't compartmentalize
work how come work
goes into your old your whole 24 hours
maybe well i'm saying uh maybe it's not
even a compartmentalizing thing
and it's more so i just don't feel big
or like i don't feel it seems like you
feel big because from like the work
stuff you'll be stressed out in a
regular day
ah [ __ ] you're right yeah i do it is a
big yeah like i'll see you later on i
won't even be able to eat yeah it's
either laying on the couch like a whole
hour i don't know what's going on you're
like i just need a ledge
i've never needed to just veg out really
yeah oh [ __ ] i don't know i'm stumped
like it takes you sometimes it takes you
a whole day to recover
and for me like take me [ __ ] weeks
for me i might just give me like 30
minutes and i'm like let's go let's go
let's do the next thing damn i need to
learn that's some [ __ ] that i need to
really learn and pay attention to
because if i could do it with us if
we're pissed
you know what i think it might be when
we're pissed like it's never really that
big of a deal right like it's either
egos clashing or
um
it's probably always ego
uh
and it's not an un
it's not like a mind-boggling
uh
problem you know i think it's more so
just egos
that like i know it's not that big of a
deal
so it's not unknown and it's not scary
to me
so that doesn't stress me out that could
be it
it could be it could be the way that i
feel emotional problems i feel it much
bigger than you do
because i maybe because i am so happy
you know maybe because i am so happy all
the time
that the minute i feel a little bit find
those buttons as soon as i feel
negativity it really [ __ ] with me
because i'm like oh [ __ ] i really hate
this feeling
it really destroys me
yeah
what does it make you feel like
when we have like a fight
well when with that that destroys you
feeling
what does that feel like
can you paint like a picture can you
give me like an analogy
it just feels like um
i just feel pissed it just feels like
like uh
like life's not worth living whoa
yeah
that's [ __ ] massive
what do you mean it makes me wanna like
just like cut my leg off or something
whoa i think i've only felt that
once or twice in my life this is prior
to also uh to me being a [ __ ]
emotional wreck as a teenager where i
really wanted to end my life
but it wasn't really even that serious
um but past that i think i've only felt
that like maybe one time no for me i
think because i'm so happy and
everything can be so happy and we could
all
choose to be happy
when it gets to that point
it makes me feel defeated like how do we
let it get here
damn
do you think you might be viewing the
situation a little too
um
serious
could be but that's how i feel
yeah yeah i'm not saying
no because you're asking me how i feel
and that's the picture i'm painting is
that how i feel i could i could be
feeling wrong but that's just how i feel
i could be thinking about it wrong but
that's how i feel i get you yeah
damn
i never knew that yeah
it feels so bad
like whenever we fight like it just
feels so bad it feels like uh it feels
like i failed you you failed me it feels
like we failed taika
it feel it just feels it feels like we
uh we just took a fat [ __ ] on the
concept of marriage to everyone in the
whole world because we all agreed that
this is what we all how we value
marriage right and we go oh you guys are
married cool like we have an
understanding right this line draws
through the whole universe we all
understand what marriage feels like it
just feels like we just took a fat [ __ ]
on it
okay so if
so your ideal
relationship
would look like what
my ideal relationship yeah would be
full of empathy
and intention base
that's how it would be
full of so yes ego sometimes comes in
the way right
i think and we're not on our a game and
stuff but i think my ideal relationship
is i always view you it would be like
both of us on ecstasy
it would it would feel like
i always have your back because i have
extreme empathy and i can only think for
you and i know all your intentions are
pure and good and you do the same to me
can you imagine having a fight on
ecstasy
it's impossible be a polite fight like
no you're the best stop yeah like that
right you're the best
ideal relationship because that's how
i try to have a relationship yeah yeah
dang
i mean i think that's literally
everyone's ideal relationship yeah but i
actually try though yeah you do which i
don't know if many people actually try
that right
you know yeah which is why like
sometimes like someone will say
something they leave the room and then
there'll be like four people kind of
like bite oh no i think maybe they meant
to like that
you know yeah like i find myself being
usually that guy yeah like oh that could
be like that because i'm just trying to
like i'm like
obviously this person's not trying to
kill us because then they would
try to kill us so
the boards probably came out wrong or
whatever and i'm sure this person has
intentions because they've been around
for like 10 years so they're probably
meaning like this you know
because they don't want to be around
they probably won't be around they just
they just leave so if they've been
around for 10 years there's a reason
yeah so let's maybe we could view it
like that you know yeah
so i try to like live as if i'm on
ecstasy with that extreme empathy yeah
to feel what people's intentions are
yeah that's a beautiful way to live and
that's why i think i get so mad or
when it gets to the point because like
we both lost empathy at each other yeah
in that moment when we're fighting not
only did i did you not have empathy for
me i also didn't have empathy for you
and i feel so bad
damn cause i was gonna say like oh maybe
you weren't exposed because i was
exposed to a lot of like
hot and cold behavior you know like
superheated super angry yelling at the
top of my lungs not throwing [ __ ] like i
didn't grow up with physical violence
um but it was definitely a lot of
emotional stressors you know
um
so like it was like a constant up and
down and it just fluctuated so
significantly
that like i i i was trying to attribute
me being comfortable in that area to
that but then you also grew up that same
way too and you're not like that well i
think the difference between you and me
i feel like you're half closed off all
the time
what do you mean like i think when i
meet people it's literally this is why i
was my [ __ ] yeah i think you're very
closed off and then when people earn
your trust you open it up open it up
more even now
even now yeah yeah i feel like i've
worked on that so hard you are way
better than you were before yeah but
you're definitely not as open as me
really yeah are you sure yeah the minute
we wake up i lay out my [ __ ] swap
meet for you to look at
right what do you mean oh like i don't
do that what do you mean like because
even when you're grumpy when you wake up
like you're already like protected i'm
kind of grumpy
we're gonna protect it well yeah i'm not
trying to give you the nasty stuff
not nasty that was the wrong word but
i'm not trying to give you the grumpy
stuff i'm trying to just contain it
but you're doing it for yourself
well i'm doing it to protect you
ultimately for yourself
no because i don't want to i don't want
you to get offended or feel sad i'm not
trying to do it let's say we wake up in
the morning right and both of our
breaths smell like [ __ ]
what do you mean let's say
okay that's literally what happened
let's say i want to smell it
would you let me smell it
no you sick fart exactly exactly because
it's for you
you could say you're warned about my
nose but ultimately you don't want
people to smell your bad bad stuff
um it's not because i'm embarrassed i
feel bad for you exactly but i told you
if i told you i'm okay with it and i
want to smell it
why won't you let me smell it that's a
good question i thought that's what i
was doing it for no then ultimately it's
for you
what am i trying to hide exactly because
if you told me i would go here you go
you would say that yeah exactly but
so that tells me i'm already like this
here's my swap meet yeah that door's
closed off already yeah and that's why i
think i go i go you know what i'm
thinking what i'm like man you're so
stupid
why do you don't even know what you want
i'm i'm a protector but you don't you
don't know how i'm gonna enjoy it and
that's not empathy right when you go
you're so stupid instead of going wow
this guy's a genius he must know how to
enjoy this better than i do
duh right that's empathy don't ever ask
me to [ __ ] on your chest or anything
because remember like when we eat with
people remember like everything i go
when someone's world renowned and this
fool's eating [ __ ] i don't know like
duck testicle and stuff most people like
for me i'm like if he's a michelin star
chef and he says this duck testicle is
good i have low quality taste buds that
means i need to i stop there i need to
keep eating this until i experience what
he experienced then i have elevated my
palate yeah right so i try to operate
with empathy where i'm like what does
this guy know that i don't know
obviously i'm not in his realm
and then so that's the same thing where
uh if if you had
if i had bad breath instead of going
you're stupid you don't know what you're
smelling if you go this guy must not be
a genius that's a different flip so i
think you already start off you're a
superior human i think you're already
controlled like this yeah and i just
start off like this so i think when i'm
like this when i get stabbed in the
heart it hurts like crazy but i think
for you sincerity like this it goes
through the armor first it might go
in the heart a little bit you know cause
you've already been kind of protected
yeah but i'm already like
full like open for for whatever to
happen so i think when i get hurt it
hurts me so bad
you've been cuny because like you're
saying all these vulnerable things and
you still have that white ass tissue in
your i mean in your nose and it's super
cute because like i could see you saying
it as like
four-year-old bart
um
and that's that's really cuny and i
think it's such a superior thing why is
it superior
because you're very vulnerable and to be
very vulnerable you have to be you have
to be very humble and to be very humble
you have to have
little to no ego as as possible right
and then when you're able to diminish
your ego then you're able to
learn so much
you're able to take in so much you know
which contributes to you already being
smart and then just becoming even
smarter because you're just so receptive
to so much information that you're not
even uh
held back by because you're not viewing
it as negative or positive you're just
viewing this information as information
and it's just
all [ __ ]
getting into your [ __ ] motherboard
yeah
and you're just [ __ ] eating it all up
you're like a little information pacman
that's [ __ ] super cool
i'm i'm really trying to uh
understand my parts
the parts in my life that um are super
guarded by ego
i'm even reading a book on ego right now
it's called uh ego is the enemy because
i'm really just trying to and it's so
funny because as i'm reading it i
realize right now there's still so much
ego
because as i'm reading it i'm like duh
yeah i know that obviously what's one
other thing that's so much ego as you're
reading it like staying humble right
like it once like literally what i just
said about you like if you're humble
then um
you can be more vulnerable you can take
in more information
you tend to be more on the quiet side
because you're literally just trying to
learn and listen and just be present
right and i'm going yeah obviously
you know instead of just going like
instead of
trying to work
out
that's the truth oh yeah like being on
that person's side yeah you're already
like duh you just know this just skip
chapters please yeah yeah yeah you know
like i hear myself
fighting myself
and as i read it i'm like yeah obviously
and then i'm going yeah [ __ ] obviously
but you're not doing it and i'm like
yeah you're right you know so i'm like
constantly [ __ ] going back and forth
in my mind
of going like yeah yeah [ __ ] loser
shut the [ __ ] up you don't know [ __ ] you
talk to god that much i'm like oh yeah
you're so right
you know as i'm reading this book that's
good
what's good that i said yeah [ __ ] shut
your mouth yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] you
yeah i know it's super cool
it's super cool maybe your whole
happiness state
um of being could be a bunch of things
right it could be genetic it could be uh
preconditioning it could be just
examples like your mom or whatever
um but all of that
kind of just reinforces the fact that
you don't run on ego
i try not to i'm sure we all run on ego
of course i just try i mean ego is not
ego is also like we see ego as a bad
thing but it's also a good ego is just
ego right like it's there to protect us
from
things
obviously but i think when we lean into
that too much then that's when it's the
way that i see it is uh
all those things right like ego
empathy all of those things they're
they're like energy sources almost like
a battery yeah
and or like a power source
like a flame actually like fire
and i think um
it's all dependent on the usage yeah
to
keep warm or [ __ ] burning all the
bridges exactly to be beneficial
or to be detrimental yeah because it
cook because extreme
uh empathy
is also bad yeah because then someone
can like literally come up to you
and then go
give me your [ __ ] money i'm gonna
blow your brains out and you're like oh
this guy poor guy
daddy issues and oh man i just feel so
bad for you he just [ __ ] blows your
brains out because you didn't give him
the money because you have too much
empathy you know so i think like
everything it has it's a power that's
energy source and you got to use or you
could be an enabler yeah and you got to
use it you know
so um so even with like the ego thing i
think it's really important to have but
to channel it in a healthy way right
but uh
one of the reasons why i think people
don't try [ __ ]
and actually limit their growth
is because ego you know i don't want to
look like that on roller skates i don't
want to look like that in dance class
i'm not going to fit in you know and
it's just all this like i i i and then
you end up not doing jack [ __ ] and
staying in your comfort zone and then
you just ultimately doesn't grow
which also your ego is just being
nurtured in a very negative way yeah and
then your self-esteem goes down and like
it's just a whole bad cycle you know
yeah
yeah um that was one thing i noticed
recently
with just watching tyka play so right
now he's really into drums yeah um
so like
thank god right because we got him a
drum set how long ago maybe two years
ago i got him he was two yeah in hopes
that he would just be curious about it
and it's not until he's like almost five
that he's like oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
banging his chest making beats [ __ ]
on his on his lap and stuff and um i see
him play on the drums and i just see him
completely be free
and i and it was really cool to see that
because i only hang out with people my
age right like how weird would it be
around with kids if i'm not getting paid
to do so so like i don't really get to
see pure freedom because after a certain
age two kids start feeling that ego and
like start feeling different things
where they're like now shy or reserved
or like they hold back
um
it might not be eagle but it might be
other reasons but
when i was watching tyka play he was
just so free
like he didn't care to like
um
play
holding like you you could see him just
experimenting like i'm gonna hold the
drum the the sticks this way i'm gonna
instead of using sticks i'm gonna use
this like you can see his wheels turning
and he didn't care what he looked like
he didn't care who was listening it was
literally me
i was he was allowing me to be in his
world
and it wasn't like he wasn't trying to
share a world nor was he trying to live
in my world right because we all live in
our own world
uh regardless if we believe it or not
but we all live in our own like we're
literally just walking around with our
[ __ ] invisible headphones
in our own head yeah um but taika like
watching him experiment and play and
like
explore
it was just so refreshing and i'm like
[ __ ] it showed me how far removed i am
from that
and it really showed me like how much
ego i i um i run off of well i don't
know if it really showed me but it
definitely put that into my face more
yeah it's a good comparison to see yeah
yeah so as i was watching him do that
i'm like [ __ ]
i need to be more like that because it
doesn't matter so
um i've been reading a lot more
these past couple of years and i don't i
i don't tend to read just one book at a
time i like
any free time i have i'm either
listening to a book or i'm reading a
book or i'm i'm just trying to take in
just different schools of thought and it
doesn't matter what realm
of like literature i'm reading whether
it's self-help or business or finance or
just
maybe not fiction
i don't really read too much fiction for
whatever reason
um
it they always tell you
literally every [ __ ]
realm
genre
is always like
nobody knows anything
right like even scientists they're
probably the closest to knowing
something but then this new discovery
happens and now everything they knew has
completely changed to [ __ ] you really
didn't even know yeah and it's crazy to
me because i'm like
you know growing up you think
adults no more or teachers or doctors or
all these other people have it figured
out and literally those same people are
letting you know like i don't know
anything we can't predict anything we
really do not know [ __ ]
and like knowing that
i'm going [ __ ] i really have to let go
of whatever
you know i'm holding on to that prevents
me from trying new things or saying
things or being more open or not having
this like
guard that you just mentioned i have all
the [ __ ] time you know what's crazy
is you'll notice like the top the
highest level coaches and professors
they're the most humblest ones yeah
because they actually know the most but
they know they don't know [ __ ] they know
that they it's barely scratching the
surface
so the guys that
are at the top are usually the ones that
go i don't know [ __ ] and what's crazy
it's like the middle to the lower level
coaches that are always like i know
everything and this is dogma you can't
change it yeah isn't that crazy that is
crazy
yeah but i don't know i gotta be more
like bart we all gotta be more like fart
i don't know i don't know that's a good
thing i know i know you have your
moments um of genius we all have our
moments of genius but for sure
i gotta strive to be more like that so
if you ask me to [ __ ] smell my stinky
breath
i'll let you smell my secret breath you
just can't make fun of me
it goes back what it goes back to your
ego
see that's the true colors though it
goes right back to your ego and that's
why you don't want me to i know
i know but i think i'm our brain is so
complex and so [ __ ] smart that it'll
justify why it's not ego which further
[ __ ]
solidifies
the minute you need to justify something
it's ego all right dude stop calling me
out so much this whole podcast i've been
calling myself out you've been calling
myself out i get it
i'm a work in [ __ ] progress okay that
orange tops ego i've been telling you
hey it's a cute top it is cute thank you
all right well
seems like we've reached the end of our
podcast
anything you want to say [ __ ]
cinnamon roll nose this time i actually
do okay and that's it thank you guys so
much
for watching and listening you guys do
not i'm just kidding so this time i
actually do
and um i get a lot of dms
and people like wanting to know about
entrepreneurship
and uh my thought process i even get
those dms for you really yeah that's all
cool and like and like just kind of how
i plan or design my life
and i always figured like man
i've made a lot of mistakes in the last
like 10 15 years because i haven't had a
mentor and just just like comparing how
it took seven or eight years for jk to
break seven figures and then for bar
brigade to do the same thing in like
four years it just shows the more you
know like the faster successes right
right so um i'm starting a mentorship
program actually
congratulations i'm so when you said
this was happening happening i'm so
excited for everyone to like get a piece
of you because
you're just so inspiring oh thank you
mama yeah but don't don't i'm never
gonna say that again fine and so yeah
i'm starting it um and if you guys are
interested just look out i'm still
working on it and the back end but i do
have a name and it's called times 100.
there you go and it's because i realize
everything that you do every single
second
at the end of
a certain period whatever you do is the
sum of the period before it so you're
literally like your times 100 of what
you do now yeah so that's why i think
it's so important to be very aware of
how you process things plan things
prioritize things and so the mentorship
group that i'm starting it's going to be
like um pretty much like a segmented
class each time so that we can focus on
this group of people if they want to do
it again that's perfect but there's a
beginning or end and we walk through a
bunch of lessons and principles that i
live my life by and then uh from there
take a little break and then we'll start
like the next class up so stay tuned for
that if you see me talking about times
100 you know where you guys saw it first
it'll be on my instagram and i believe
this mentorship group will be ready in a
few weeks so just stay tuned nice
all right there you go that's amazing um
don't sleep on that trust me bart is a
very unique person it's someone that you
definitely want to model your life off
off of and by like i mean you're just
such a righteous dude you're just such a
straight [ __ ] arrow i'm just so
stoked that you're gonna share that with
the world um thank you so much for
watching and listening and we'll catch
you guys next time bye bye